tennessee congressman jim cooper
becoming the 29th house democrat call it
quits as polls show republicans are now
the favorites to win in november brian
kilmeade is here he is a host of fox and
friends he is here with us at 5 55 a.m
which means that he got dressed early
this morning right and we thank you for
that brian we talk about these
retirements a lot when you see 29
democrats retiring what comes to mind
couple of things uh clearly the momentum
is on the
uh on the republican side and i just
think nancy pelosi saw what paul ryan
did a few years ago when he felt as
though he was going to lose his
speakership and he said i have an idea
i'm going to retire in two years but i'm
going to hold on to the job it was a
disaster for the party it was a two year
uh i lost uh a flashing light and i
think nancy pelosi comes out and says
yeah i'm coming back number one to say
that i'm still a force don't uh don't
exclude me from all the meetings and
number two is i believe there is a
chance and there's two things that could
happen number one joe biden could act
heroically and hedge off an invasion and
suddenly look like a man in charge and
number two if the supreme court justice
nomination goes smoothly he again could
uh increase the competence scale from
zero to maybe uh five then all of a
sudden dem
uh democrats might feel as though there
is additional hope for the midterms but
you got to feel good if you're in the
gop
brian um if there's one thing that
everybody says around here it's like
kill me needs to work more
it's a common refrain you hear it in the
hallways we just understand why you are
so lazy all joking aside you got a big
show coming up on the weekend your 87th
hour of weekend pro programming on the
channel we're looking forward to it it's
called one nation what can you tell us
about greatness well first off that we
got a name uh which is pretty cool uh
there's a lot of things that were all
locked up and uh patents uh but it's
gonna be uh looking back at the biggest
stories looking ahead at the biggest
stories and putting into context i think
we're gonna have a situation where i'm
not looking to divide and maybe cool the
temperatures down a little bit while
increasing people's knowledge about
what's happening out there amongst our
guests in the first week we're going to
go out to the ukraine by vitaly
klitschko he is the mayor there and a
former heavyweight champ that actually
beat lennox lewis well at six foot seven
he's going to need more than 5 000
helmets from the germans in order to
survive a russian invasion uh we're
going to talk to him and also michael
ruzzione should we be going to china and
play in the winter olympics how does he
feel about that as compared to lake
placid winning in 1980 he did actually
change the mood in the country helped do
that when his 1980 team beat the soviets
at the time could we do that by going
over to what many people are calling the
genocide games talk to mike ruzioni
about that and then we'll have other
times to fill so i might sing and
possibly dance would you guys know i
really excel at it he loves to dance
professional foreign policy discussions
it's a natural fit you also have a fox
nation special what makes america great
what's that about new episodes they
include ellis island it was a thrill for
me i had to miss fox and friends but i
went there before it opened six in the
morning and i lived where i really felt
like i was time traveling where 12
million future americans came in the
hope of getting the thumbs up and
allowed to go ashore in the backdrop of
the statue of liberty and then teddy
roosevelt he's not just a two-term
president he was the first police
commissioner of new york what he did to
transform this police force that changed
police forces around the country with
ray kelly who idolized him growing up
lived in the same neighborhood of the
museum in natural history and at the
same time used his desk as bratton did
and perhaps this uh uh this police chief
is doing and what he meant so also what
he did for first generation immigrants
he did this crazy thing uh todd and
carly when he wanted to increase the
life and make that uh better in new york
city he took out the buildings and built
a park and that park still exists today
over in five points in downtown new york
city so we look back at that brian fox
and friends starts in 30 seconds so the
big question is and we need a short
answer from you are you going to make it
to the couch on time what are the next
seconds of your life looking like we
might run yesterday's show it was so
good we might run a repeat uh because
i'm really concerned about going five
feet uh we'll see sorry
all right sorry
all joking aside nobody does a long form
interview quite as well as kill me yeah
both of those are going to be great hi
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now